pourquoi je crois encore la droite parce
que malgré nos épreuves la droite porte
en elle cette France que je porte en moi
cette France des valeurs aussi du
travail qui rend digne des racines qui
rendent fortes
cette France de l'honneur parce que rien
ne peut tenir debout sans ces
convictions qui nous tiennent trop
souvent la droite a reculer je ne
reculerai pas relevons la droite pour
relever la France relevons ce qui fera
demain sa prospérité la liberté relevant
notre état pour qu'il protège et
relevant notre drapeau relevons notre
fierté celle d'appartenir à une grande
nation produit d'une grande civilisation
soyons prêts pour la France avec de
nouvelles idées avec un nouveau parti
plus moderne plus démocratique aussi car
je veux que pour se donner un nouvel
élan la droite vous redonne la parole à
vous les militants
vous êtes le cœur battant de la droite
vous êtes le cœur ardent de la France
ensemble faisons battre nos cœurs
français pour la droite et pour la
France